Some of the most famous and notable SCPs in
the database are what some of us would call
monsters.
I bet you can think of some off the top of
your head, right?
Everyone even loosely familiar with the SCP
Foundation can recall some anomalies that
are famous not because of their history, or
their power, but because of their terrifying
tendency to prey on humans indiscriminately.
There’s the legendary SCP-682, which is
the perfect predator.
Invulnerable to any kind of attack or wound,
it instantly adapts to whatever was used to
attack it and regenerates any lost flesh or
material.
It’s not just hard to kill - it can be downright
impossible, though the Foundation is constantly
working on some new technique and hoping for
success.
In case that wasn’t all terrible enough,
it’s also actively hateful of all life around
it, seeking to exterminate every living thing.
Or take SCP-939, a pack of four-legged beasts
with bright red skin and ice-cold bodies.
They work together to lure in prey and tear
unsuspecting researchers and civilians to
pieces with their long, sharp teeth.
You might be thinking that their tactics don’t
sound too different from any other pack predator,
like wolves or coyotes.
But wolves and coyotes don’t steal the voices
of people they’ve eaten, then use the voices
to lure in other humans.
Needless to say, the SCP-939 instances are
under intense surveillance.
And who can forget about SCP-106?
The famous Old Man, who preys upon the living
and sucks the unwary children and D-class
into his pocket dimension, where he can engage
in an eternal game of cat-and-mouse with them.
Unlike the others, SCP-106 isn’t just predatory,
it’s downright sadistic.
It likes to play with its food and enjoys
the struggle of watching them try to escape.
The Foundation barely has a handle on how
to contain it, and they’re constantly hoping
that it doesn’t try to breach containment
and result in even more innocent casualties.
You can see why the SCP Foundation is so wary
and paranoid about SCPs that are predators
preying on humans.
At least not directly.
Instead, SCP-1788 is a specific kind of process,
treatment, or ritual.
The Foundation’s researchers aren’t totally
confident on what it is yet, but they know
that whatever it is, it causes a frightening,
horrifying transformation on whoever the unwilling
We call these creatures SCP-1788-1 instances.
The Foundation currently has no idea who or
what created SCP-1788 and why, but they’re
performing active and constant research, including
investigating all the groups of interest who
They’re almost always obese - in fact, once
they’re fully grown, they appear anywhere
from a hundred and fifty to two hundred kilograms.
But don’t be fooled by appearances - they
might look like they’re simply fat, but
the insides of their bodies are filled with
muscle and dense bone, making them easily
two-hundred and fifty to three hundred kilograms
in actual weight.
We’ll go into their internal anatomy more
in a second, but for now let's return to the
outside of their bodies.
When you look at someone’s face, what’s
the first thing you notice?
It can be their nose, their hair, but nine
times out of ten, it’s probably their eyes.
And SCP-1788-1 instances might fool you in
that regard - their eyes are slightly too
large for their face, just enough to weird
you out if you looked at them, though you
probably wouldn’t be able to put your finger
on what exactly was wrong about them.
When instances get hot and perspire, their
sweat is chemically unbalanced - it has high
levels of potassium and copper, enough to
show up on tests but still firmly in the normal
range for adult humans.
As you can see, the changes to SCP-1788-1
instances from the outside are pretty hard
to tell.
But on the inside, it’s a totally different
story.
Their internal anatomy has been extensively
changed.
During the first dissections, the Foundation
researchers didn’t even realize these creatures
were originally human at first.
The instances’ long bones, such as the ones
in their arms and legs, and cranium, are super
dense and thick, more so than any normal human.
And they’re not just made of bone, either
- they’re interwoven with thick strands
of heavy metals, making them super-strong
and powerful.
Their muscles, on the other hand, have been
reinforced in a totally different way.
The researchers are still studying tissue
samples, but it seems that the muscle fibers
have been modified into shapes resembling
carbon nanotubes, molecular structures that
are super-light while still being stronger
than steel.
Evidence derived from numerous physical tests
run on the instances have shown that because
of these structural modifications, SCP-1788-1
instances are much, much stronger, faster,
and have the ability to withstand punishment
far beyond the threshold of any normal humans.
SCP-1788-1 instances also possess redundant
organ systems for several of the human body’s
vital processes - backup organs, basically.
When one of a normal human's primary organs
stop working, they usually die, but SCP-1788-1
instances can just switch to using the backup
organ and keep going.
The most obvious example is the fact that
they have a second heart, and it can either
function independently if the main heart stops
working, or it can work together with the
main heart to give the instance much faster
respiration and breathing abilities.
That’s part of why they’re able to move
so fast.
Speaking of their circulatory system, some
of their blood vessels have locks that can
organs.
That’s right; SCP-1788-1 instances have
a second brain.
Rather than in the head, the second brain
is located in the chest inside its own ribcage.
The researchers are baffled by this part of
the SCP-1788-1 instance’s anatomy - they
haven’t been able to figure out what this
brain does normally when the first brain is
still working.
But they have seen that if the first brain
is destroyed, this second brain can take over
to some limited capacity.
They saw this firsthand when a team of Foundation
agents lured an SCP-1788-1 instance into a
killzone, and an MTF sniper blew open its
head.
But despite its brain and most of its sensory
function being utterly destroyed, the monster
kept going and was able to subdue other agents
before being brought down.
Another main difference in the overall anatomy
of an SCP-1788-1 instance from a normal human
is its arms.
More specifically, that it has extra arms.
A second pair of arms sit just below the regular
main arms, extending out of the armpits.
They’re much smaller, but they’re just
as strong and flexible, and testing has shown
that SCP-1788-1 instances can use all four
arms at the same time if they need to.
But to maintain their cover, most of the time
instances just hold the second arms folded
up and close to their sides, where nobody
can tell they’re there from the instances’
massive size.
When an instance is wearing clothes and has
their arms folded up, it’s almost impossible
to tell which is an SCP-1788-1 instance and
which is just a normal, if obese human being.
As you can see, SCP-1788 causes quite a few
drastic changes to the human body.
In fact, you could probably say that these
creatures aren’t even properly human anymore.
But despite all these changes, SCP-1788-1
instances are, as you can also see, really
hard to differentiate from regular humans.
The perfect stealth predator, right?
But what exactly do instances do with all
these additional abilities and modifications?
Well, like we said, the second part of SCP-1788
changes the behavior of the people it infects.
Namely, they become...
predatory.
The behavior of SCP-1788 instances was hard
to observe, since finding them at all was
such a difficult task, but eventually the
research team located a large group of SCP-1788-1
instances living in the same large metropolitan
city.
The Foundation set up covert observation teams,
stakeouts, reconnaissance agents, and essentially
blanketed the city in a net of surveillance.
Before long, every little movement and action
of the SCP-1788-1 instances was recorded in
the Foundation's database.
They observed that as soon as SCP-1788-1 instances
hit adulthood, they would typically settle
down in large cities, just like the one the
Foundation was staking out.
They'd find a job - most would be in white
collar work and middle-management, but one
thing that became evident was that none of
them would ever work as teachers, nurses,
or any other job where they would come into
regular contact with kids.
Once the Foundation realized what was going
on, they also realized there was nothing else
to learn from just observing them.
They had to get an instance into containment
to try and interrogate them.
A lot of good agents lost their lives in the
multiple attempts that were made to tranquilize,
sedate, capture or otherwise lure SCP-1788-1
instances into containment, but eventually
a few were shot up with enough tranquilizer
to bring down an elephant and dragged back
to the site.
But all attempts to force the SCP-1788-1 in
the containment cells to surrender any knowledge
failed.
They seemed invulnerable to pain - torture,
coercion, interrogation, all methods failed
to glean any important knowledge about their
motives from them.
But all the instances the Foundation captured...
well, the personnel who contained and researched
them could only describe them as deeply evil.
They were cruel and narcissistic.
They would only speak to communicate their
superiority over their captors, and mock personnel
They weren't stupid, though - quite the opposite.
The researchers recorded very high IQs and
problem-solving skills during intelligence
tests, and they'd often psychoanalyze their
own researchers into revealing details about
themselves.
It didn't take long for the Site Directors
to ban all human contact with captured instances,
lest they manipulate personnel into freeing
them.
Meanwhile, in the city, surveillance teams
were still monitoring instances that couldn't
be captured by the Foundation's strike teams.
They watched them at their jobs, in their
cars and at their homes.
They noticed that despite there being about
half a dozen SCP-1788-1 instances in that
one city, they seemed to intentionally avoid
each other at all costs.
They took jobs at different companies, lived
in different parts of town, shopped at different
By sheer coincidence, three SCP-1788-1 instances
showed up at the same sporting event.
They seemed to instantly realize what was
going on, and all left the stands at the same
time.
The undercover agents on duty followed, and
tracked them to the bathrooms.
There, they discovered a grisly sight.
The SCP-1788-1 instances were in the deserted
bathroom, violently beating each other against
the walls with all four of their fists.
They were hitting hard, with no regard for
their 'cover' identities, and spraying blood
against the floor.
They were fighting not for survival, but to
establish dominance.
The gender didn't seem to matter - the female
instance was fighting just as brutally as
the two male ones, and being beaten just as
harshly.
After several minutes of this violent show
of force, two of the instances retreated out
of the bathroom, submitting the territory
to the dominant victor of the fight.
They quickly left the event entirely.
The Foundation confirmed this with the few
instances they had contained - when two were
put in the same cell, they'd fight for dominance.
They quickly realized it was important to
ensure that instances were kept separate at
all times, lest they kill each other and rob
the Foundation of a living test subject.
There weren't many instances to begin with
- while multiple of the monsters were observed
in the same city, they kept a strict ratio
of 1 SCP-1788-1 instance for every 100,000
humans.
The same behavior apex predators like bears
and sharks practice.
This behavior of avoiding each other happens
for almost the entire calendar year.
At first, the Foundation thought this avoiding
practice never stopped.
But about a year into the surveillance program,
something seemed to change.
Several of the tagged SCP-1788-1 instances
in the city actively began to gravitate towards
each other's territories.
The Foundation prepared for the inevitably
brutal fights, but something even stranger
happened - they met each other and didn't
fight.
In fact, they went to each other's homes.
The recon teams reported that the SCP-1788-1
instances were in fact mating with one another.
Apparently an annual mating season caused
this change in behavior.
Needless to say, SCP-1788-1 instances are
horrifying apex predators.
The Foundation's research and observation
teams have gleaned quite a bit about their
anatomy and behavior, respectively, but many
of the personnel still hold the burning question:
why?
Why do SCP-1788-1 instances hunt?
What's the motivation?
Well, their uncooperativeness with interviews
makes finding out any details into their thought
process virtually impossible.
However, there was one occurrence where one
of the captured instances accidentally let
something slip.
One of the Site Directors was attempting to
interrogate an instance using an electroshock
collar.
it gave a simple, sneering response: "Grow
up.
Or die."
Now go check out “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” and “SCP-053 - Young
Girl” for more kid-related anomalies from
SCP Explained!